i have the complex number three minus
four i've plotted it on the complex
plane we see that the real part is three
we've so we've gone three along the
horizontal axis or the real axis and the
imaginary part is negative four so we've
gone down four along the vertical axis
so this right here is the point 3 minus
4i
now what i want to think about is what
the absolute value of 3 minus 4i is and
just as a reminder absolute value
literally means whether we're talking
about a complex number or a real number
it literally just means distance away
from zero so the absolute value of three
minus four i is going to be the distance
between zero between the origin on the
complex plane and
and
that point adding the point 3 minus 4i
so this distance right over is going to
be the absolute value
of 3
minus 4i
so how can we think about that
well we could literally just set up a
right triangle and then use the
pythagorean theorem
so let's think about it if we wanted to
set up a right triangle
we want to set up a right triangle the
height here
the height here well we went
the distance between zero and negative
four well that distance is going to be 4
and then the base of this triangle the
distance between 0 and 3 is just going
to be 3
it's going to be 3 and this is
definitely a right angle this is a
horizontal line this is a vertical line
we can now use the pythagorean theorem
to figure out the absolute value of 3
minus 4i the distance between this point
and 0. it's the hypotenuse of this right
triangle so we just use the pythagorean
theorem this side squared 3 squared
plus this side squared plus 4 squared is
going to be equal to it's going to be
equal to the absolute value of 3 minus
4i
3 minus 4i
squared
the absolute value squared so 3 squared
plus 4 squared that's 9 plus 16 which is
25 so you get 25 is equal to the
absolute value of 3 minus 4i squared
3
minus 4i
and we know if you take the absolute
value of something this is just a
distance it's going to be positive so we
want to take the positive square root
the principal square root of both sides
of this and so we're going to be left
with well the principle square root the
positive square root of 25 is 5 is equal
to the absolute value of 3 minus 4i 3
minus 4i
so another way of saying it this thing
right over here is going to be equal to
5. this distance right over here is
equal to 5. now without having to draw
it one way you could just think about
this is i'll have my real part i have my
imaginary part i could literally take
each of those parts square them take the
sum and take the square root so another
way of taking it if you didn't want to
visualize all of this but this is really
what we're doing you could say well this
is just going to be equal to
take the real part squared it's going to
take the real part squared take the
imaginary part squared
so let me write this so the imaginary
part
squared
add them together
add them together and then take the
square root so that's score or the
principal root so that's going to be the
principle roots just a positive square
root so that's going to be the square
root of
9 plus 16
plus 16 which once again is equal to 5.